bonjour à tous je m'appelle Virginie
doré j'ai 30 ans je viens de la salineo
je possède donc le permis B je suivais
éculée je recherche un emploi dans
l'événementiel donc l'événementiel
sportif culturel ou dans le tourisme au
niveau de mes études j'ai obtenu une
Licence 3 STAPS ensuite j'ai enchaîné
par un MBA en management des entreprises
de l'hôtellerie restauration et tourisme
j'ai également un master 1 en meft j'ai
fait deux stages un à l'étranger à
Nottingham en tant que chef de rang dans
un hôtel dans un boutique hôtel et un
deuxième stage à Paris au Marriott dans
la partie événementielle j'ai également
une expérience professionnelle de deux
ans à l'Alliance Française des
Seychelles en tant que responsable
culturel type festival dîner-spectacle
alors je recherche un emploi à la
Réunion mais également à l'étranger
particulièrement la région
Océan Indien à fricostrale les gens
disent de moi en général que je suis
persévérant créative j'aime le travail
d'équipe j'ai un bon relationnel je suis
organisée d'ailleurs je fais du
volley-ball depuis 12 ans et tout
particulièrement le beachollet j'aime
chanter j'aime danser j'aime beaucoup
également le cinéma si vous êtes
intéressé contactez-moi je serai très
heureuse de faire partie de votre équipe